in this video I'm going to give you a
plan for learning data science in the
year 2024 now watch till the very end
cuz I'm going to lay out the steps in
order of how I think you should
prioritize them and even some resources
that I recommend I'm Richard and this is
Richard on data so one of the things
that can be really intimidating for
people just getting into data science or
even people with a few years of
experience is the sheer number of things
out there that it feels like you need to
learn should you learn r or python
should you learn aure AWS or Google
Cloud platform or do you even need to
learn any of those at all and honestly
it's basically impossible to know every
topic at a level that's going to get you
every job out there but ultimately you
want to give yourself a good foundation
learn some fundamentals and set yourself
up to have the best possible chance at
as many jobs as possible and that's what
I'm going to help you with in this video
so if you haven't subscribed to my
channel already please do that and take
just a fraction of a second to smash the
like button and let's get to it now one
of the first things you want to do is
think about what kind of data science
job that you actually want do you have a
particular industry that you're
interested in because and this is just
an example if you're interested in the
healthc care Pharma academic or maybe
Financial sectors you might end up using
R but by contrast if you're in an
engineering OR tech company you're
almost certainly never going to use r
you're probably going to be an all
python shop and do you want to go in the
office or do you want to be remote cuz
if you want a remote job there's going
to be more of those out there but those
jobs are likely to be more competitive
so it wouldn't be a bad idea to start by
looking at some of the jobs that you're
interested in and just look at some of
their descriptions and the skills
required now it's important to note that
almost every job is going to look a lot
different in practice than what you see
in the description and even in the
required ir ments and qualifications a
lot of jobs will talk a big game about
how many machine learning algorithms
they want you to have expertise in and
then on the actual job you're going to
spend most of your time writing SQL but
still if you're seeing certain topics
come up again and again like let's say
matplot lib XG boost
AWS you might want to make note of that
now I'm going to assume for the sake of
this video that you're somebody who has
some basic math knowledge up through
maybe an intro calculus or even a
pre-calculus level and you're also
somebody that has or is planning to have
soon a college degree I've made a video
about this before but it is possible to
get a data science job without a college
degree but there's no question it will
be a lot harder so for those of you who
don't have one or you're still in school
finishing up and getting that degree is
probably the single most important thing
that you could do and ideally that
degree would be something that's at
least somewhat close so something like
statistics computer science mathematics
even economics is fine but then assuming
you've got that degree in hand what's
the very first thing that you should
learn well believe it or not the first
thing i' recommend that you get some
experience with is chat GPT and there
are a lot of reasons for this first of
all chat GPT is an example of what's
known as a large language model or llm
and if you're a strong data scientist or
engineer you might find yourself working
on one of these sooner than you probably
think and it's kind of a useful thought
experiment for somebody aspiring to
break into data science or engineering
how exactly these things can come into
being and how they might work hopefully
that will be a little inspiring but even
beyond that chat GPT has enormous
practical value for one thing there's
tons of ways that chat GPT can help you
learn basically any topic a lot faster
there's plenty of videos out there I
like on exactly this topic and I'll have
links in the description but also just
generally it's increasingly likely
you'll be using chat GPT or a similar
llm a lot at the job you eventually end
up doing so it's definitely worth
investing some time getting really good
at prompt engineering just keep in mind
that while chat GPT is enormously
helpful for some programmatic tasks it
is not a substitute for actually knowing
some of the core skills like the ones
I'm about to get into it does get things
wrong and when it does it's really good
at bsing and you'll just generally think
through problems a lot better if your
abilities are strong on their own two
feet so now that we've got that out of
the way let's talk about some of the
actual data science content that you're
going to need to learn I've always been
an advocate for learning statistics
first and foremost and the reason for
that is a programming language will sort
of give you a how statistics however
will give you a what and the underlying
business will give you the why on one
hand you've got some seemingly pretty
boring stuff like te tests or
distributions but you end up working
yourself up and learning tools like
regression models or survival analysis
and these are some really practical
things that you're probably going to end
up using all the time for solving real
world problems and not only that
statistics is going to give you a great
foundation for learning machine learning
and AI obviously statistics is an
extremely broad topic so you're going to
want something pretty comprehensive for
learning this if you've already taken at
least a few courses at a university
level you're probably in pretty good
shape if not that's where something like
corsera or Con Academy will come in and
I'll have some links to courses in the
description after that you need to make
sure that you have a solid foundation in
SQL the reason for this is because
virtually all data that you'll encounter
in the real world is going to be large
and multi- relational so you're going to
need to get it in a different kind of
format in order to be able to do pretty
much anything with it so you're going to
have to know things like window
functions like maybe you have a data set
and you need to assign a rank order to
the rows and you certainly need to know
things like inner and outer joins for
squl a book that I highly recommend that
really took my own SQL to the next level
is the guru's guide to transact SQL like
everything else the link to that will be
in the description once you have your
statistical foundation and you know SQL
it raises the question should you learn
python or R now this question has been
around for nearly a decade now and my
answer to this has changed slightly over
the years but to me it looks like this
so in general neither of these two
languages are going to be rocket science
to learn but there's no question python
is the bigger and more popular of the
two and it's going to be used in more
total jobs so when in doubt I have to
defer to recommending That You Learn
Python but that's not a rule that's
necessarily going to just apply to
everybody for example I get a lot of you
tell me that you learned R in school and
if that's the case for you you probably
should just go ahead and get really good
at R and again if you're somebody who's
interested in a field like Pharma or
academic research there is a pretty good
chance that the people around you are
going to use R not python so if that's
you that I might deprioritize python a
little bit because ultimately you do
want to get really good at one of these
two languages but just know that overall
python is going to increase your
marketability a little bit more and it's
going to open you up to a ton of
different opportunities now everybody
learns a little bit differently and
there's no right or wrong way to learn
these languages for example some people
might do better with books some people
might do better with courses either way
you are going to have to get your hands
dirty doing some actual programming it's
not enough just to read a book or to
watch a video about a programming
language and then expect that you're
going to retain it you do have to write
actual code and that's where doing
projects is going to be helpful so
there's tons of beginner projects out
there on places like GitHub or driven
data or kegle and as you start working
on a few of these you'll start
developing a little portfolio for
yourself which is really going to help
you stand out so once you have those
three things statistics SQL and at least
one of those two programming languages
ideally both not to mention you know how
to prompt engineer and chat GPT you
really are in an excellent position to
break into data science however that's
just for entering remember that learning
never stops and experience is important
so you are going to run into a ton of
jobs where these three things by
themselves are simply not enough you do
have to be constantly UPS Skilling now I
would let your findings from some jobs
that you found that you're interested in
kind of be your biggest guide here but
in general here's some additional topics
that I'd recommend getting good at you
want to know the way around the terminal
on your Windows or Mac and know just a
little bit of command line programming
there's all kinds of instances where
you'll need to know how to do this and
just in general it's really good for
building intuition you'll also
definitely want to know git and be
comfortable working in GitHub these are
industry standard tools for version
controlling code and collaborating with
other developers and they get used
everywhere and then machine learning is
an obvious thing which I'm going to put
in its own separate category away from
foundational statistics so this covers
everything from simpler algorithms like
trees or ensembles of trees like random
forests all the way up to more
complicated methods like implementing
deep learning using tensorflow and Caris
I will say that some people get a little
bit carried away here so I'd recommend
not going too crazy with machine
learning until you're sure you have all
the fundamentals down but there's tons
of books out there that'll help you
learn as well as courses just like any
other topic in particular Andrew in's
machine learning course on corsera is
highly popular and comprehensive so
that's probably the first resource that
I'd recommend looking at and then that
brings us to the cloud platforms so the
share of companies out there that are
developing and managing Solutions on
Prem is diminishing more and more of
them are turning to the cloud and when I
say the cloud that's usually referring
to one of three things that's Amazon web
services that is aw that's Microsoft
Azure or that's Google Cloud platform
that is gcp this is one of the more
difficult topics to get reliable
experience in unless you already have a
job where you're working with that
particular cloud provider
but like a lot of other things there are
options out there on corera or edx is
another option where you can learn these
you start working in the environment and
doing labs and you can really get some
hands-on experience or even
certifications so I hope this has been a
useful rundown and prioritized list of
some of the things that you need to
learn in order to break into data
science now if you're really disciplined
you can probably get a pretty solid
grasp of the fundamentals in about 6
months to a year but as always your
journey of learning is never going to
end even if you're somebody who has 15
plus years of experience so once you
have the fundamentals down keep on
expanding them the lucky thing is in the
year 2024 the resources to do so are
basically endless so thanks for watching
this video If you enjoyed it hit the
like button subscribe if you haven't
already also leave me a comment down
below if you're somebody who's in data
science now tell tell me how you learned
it if you're somebody who's learning now
tell me the plan that you're working on
then I'll see you all in the Noto
distant future until then Richard on
data